[Musik]
grüß gott mein name ist oberstleutnant
1000 bacher wilfried neben der
kompaniekommandant für die drei rekruten
die zur zeit das online tagebuch auf
facebook und auf youtube darstellen und
die möchte nur noch recht herzlich
bedanken für ihr interesse an der
ausbildung der grundwehrdiener und an
meiner company ich möchte aber eines zu
bedenken geben dass dies ausbildung
jetzt nur die bea kermisch und es hat
vielleicht für manche ein bisschen
langweilige themen sind wie nur ex
erzieher dienst und war von skis dienst
aber es läuft in der junge kommt bei mir
auch noch eine pa 23 und darum zeigen
wir euch jetzt das was für diese
rekruten in zwei bis drei monaten
stattfinden konnten mit der rekruten die
jetzt zur zeit bei uns sind danke für
ihr interesse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vom heutigen
unser wöchentlicher kriegsdienst du auf
dem gipfel werden
[Musik]
weiter um als erste mal unser fonds im
gerät spricht ul simulator ausgefasst
nur mit dem heute das erste mal dass ein
tor hinten über die straße normalen
gesicherten fußballsport mit 20 ordner
vorbei und der gefragte rohrmoser sind
dann leider unter beschuss kennt man
sich aus eine leere kleiner ausgefallen
und sie zu kurz waren in zwei gruppen
geteilt
die stellung und holzschutz game und der
zweite teil vom zuge ist über rechts
kommend den ansturm wie man feind
gemacht und so einen feind ausgeschaltet
heute haben uns mal die berater vom
arbeitsmarktservice österreich besucht
hier ampel und uns beim fechten wir uns
eine woche vorgestellt von der munition
drinnen hocken schierstedt der
verschluss nach vorne
bezirk bleiben danach hin dies ist ein
solo dingo also erstversorgung und
formen
dann haben sie sich oben positioniert
und haben uns nur bei unseren gefecht zu
schauen damit kann der komplette
szenario spielen und so einzelne fehler
sieht nur das mal dass der fehler machen
jetzt kann er als company.com falsche
urteile machen also ich sag ja wir
greifen dauern und der wahl war der
feind zu mir das weiß ich nicht links
gab auch versteckt das soll ich jetzt
wirklich modernen und das spart muss ja
mit der rekruten viel zu erklären dass
es ihr gleich beim ersten gruppen und
blabla was ja jeder hat sich ja selber
gesehen jeder will ich ja bemühen dass
er nicht aus bald
[Musik]